لا احد يعرف من يكونون ارهابيون مهرب
اسلحه ام مهرب
مخدرات اذا لديكم هذا المدى الجيد من
الرؤيه هناك من الخلف على طول الحدود لنرى
هنا ذلك وخلال اليوم اخذنا ضباط لنعينه
كيف ان اليمنيين يتسللون من الحدود
بامكانك ان ترى بعض الاشخاص وهم يمشون على
طول ذلك النهر ومن هنا تعلو جبال اليمن
الصخريه تقريبا بشكل عمودي انه يريني رجال
قبائل من الحوثيين الذين اطاح لتوهم
الحكومه ومركز المراقبه هذا يطل على مدى
الحدود بحيث بالامكان رؤيه كل
شيء
الان يسيطر الحوثيون وهذا واضح نعم هذا
واضح وايران تقف وراءهم بكل تاكيد انه امر
مثير للخوف حيث يعتقدون ان منافسهم على
النفوذ في المنطقه عزز قوته على حدودهم
ويقول والسعوديون انهم ينفقون ما لا يقل
عن ثلاثه مليارات دولار لبناء طرق حدوديه
وابراج مراقبه وتكنولوجيات امنيه حديثه
لاحتواء اي محاولات تسلل للارهابيين الى
اراضيهم ولكن في اعالي التلال تبدو
التضاريس متعرجه لدرجه انه لا يوجد هناك
سياج ولا يتعلق الامر بهذا الجزء فقط من
الحدود الافعوانيه مع اليمن التي يحاول
السعوديون تامينها فالجزء الاخر الشمالي
مع العراق كان هدفا في الاونه الاخيره
لهجوم من تنظيم داعش ورغم المبالغ الطائله
التي تم انفاقها على التكنولوجيا عاليه
الجوده نجح مقاتل والتنظيم في مهاجمه مركز
حدودي وقتل قائد الفرقه السعوديه واخرين
ومن اليمن توعد تنظيم القاعده وداعش بشن
هجمات على المملكه ومجرد القاء نظره اخرى
على الحدود توضح ان هناك اشخاصا مازالوا
مستمرين في القدوم هناك شخص من تلك
الناحيه هل هو احد المهربين دل المشرف على
الكاميرا فريق المراقبه على المكان الذي
يتعين ان يقصده وتحرك بالفعل تم اخذ هذا
الشخص من هنا اين توجد تلك الشاحنه على
الطريق وما ابلغنا به رجال شرطه الحدود هو
انه خلال الشهور الثلاثه الماضيه فقط
اعترضوا ما لا يقل عن 42000 شخص والمشكل
هو انه لا يمكن ضمان حقيقه هوياتهم وهل هم
مهربون ام ارهابيون جاؤوا بنا الى هذا
الرجل الذي التقطته الكاميرا من هو وماذا
يقول السلام عليكم كيف حالك ماذا تفعل
وانت تتجاوز الحدود قال لي انه فقير
واعتاد على التسلل الى السعوديه للعمل
بكيفيه غير قانونيه على مدى 20 عاما ولكن
في الاونه الاخيره وبسبب تجديد الامن على
الجانب السعودي بات الامر ينطوي على صعوبه
بالغه الان نحن في ساعه متاخره من عصر
اليوم وقد جانا الى هذه القاعده التي تضم
مهربين تم اعتقالهم ومن ضمنهم مهرب
قات انهم انهم
اطفال شاهدوا ماذا لديه لقد عرفنا ان
اصغرهم لا يتجاوز ع سنوات وهي المره
الثانيه التي يتم فيها اعتق وهو بصدد
تهريب القات مقابل 50 دولارا عن كل عمليه
ماذا ستفعلون به الجواب هو اعادته الى
اليمن لا سما ان ما تعلق به ليس سوى قطره
من محيط انظروا الى هذا الكم الهائل من
القات انها كميه هائله ويبدو انه تم جمعها
للتو لان الاوراق تبدو جديده جدا من ثلاثه
الى خمسه اطنان من القات يوميا لقد ابلغنا
انه خلال الشهور الثلاثه ماضيه وعلى طول
ال 500 ك من الحدود تم احتجاز ما لا يقل
عن نصف مليون طن اي بما يضر 100 مليون
دولار لنعود الان لنلقي نظره على ما يحدث
في السباق على اشده من اجل اعتقال رجال
بصدد الهروب وما لا افهمه حقا هو لماذا لا
يبادر الرجال بالفرار حيث انهم على ما
يبدو يرغبون في التقدم من السياج ثم تاتي
دوريه مراقبه وتلقي القبض عليهم انهم يق
قون انهم فقراء يمنيون وان سجون السعوديه
افضل من حريه اليمن وكيف تتاكدون من ان
بعضهم ليست له علاقه بجماعات ارهابيه قال
لي انه يتم اخذ بصماتهم واذا كان لديهم
سجل فان الشرطه ستعرف ومع غروب الشمس
انتقلنا الى مركز شرطه وبعد دقائق سيكون
هناك مزيد من المهربين المعتقلين اليوم
هذه الليله غدا الاسبوع المقبل وما بعده
حدود صحراء المملكه تحت وطاه
التهديد هذا ابو حسن ابو حسن